some failed this week on thug notes we
bring all the boys to the yard for The
Glass Menagerie by Tennessee woods my
man
our narrator Tom gives us the lowdown
that everything we about the people in
the stage is a memory of his and that
his daddy skipped town a long time ago
leaving his mama Amanda and her sister
Laura cashed out on the struggle so now
Tom got to be the breadwinner
it's grubbing time in the Wingfield crib
where Amanda like Laura you best keep
that ass tight to make sure the boys
will Harlem mama buggin that Laura gonna
be single forever but lord don't expect
any brothers to show up one the wool her
since she got a busted ass foot and
always acting all shines Amanda stop
running her mouth about how she was so
fine back in the day that she has
seventeen Busters and one afternoon
trying to get a crack of that ghetto
booty a man to say she could have bagged
a rich playboy but she chose that scrub
ass daddy instead later Laura make it
show her glass collection shine when
mama gets all her saying Laura why he
been going to that school I paid for
apparently Laura been ducking out and
walking around burn houses issue
Amanda Bell had it what she like girl
has there ever been a brother you wanted
a piece of yeah there was this flower
player named Jim back in high school
who used to call me blue roses but Jim
was too happened in the kickee with
Laura couple months later Amanda getting
all in Tom's grill when he snapped and
say woman stop riding my nuts trying to
control me I'm the one bringing home the
bread Tom peace out to the movies but
momma say he probably doing some
scandalous brother car girl winch and
bales next morning Tom apologizes for
being a dick and say he'd go to the
movies cuz he chosen for a life of
adventure momma say boy you better get
your head out of your ass we got to make
plans for Laura hooker robber one of the
warehouse boys you work with so later
Tom tell his mommy he's got a do name
O'Connor dropping by
Amanda losses are trying to prep and Tom
say chill he don't even know about Laura
I mean real talk she crippled and spent
all day with her glass
next night time start talking about that
boy Jim who Laura used to have the hots
for dude was balling man he had man hoop
skills was the president of Harry damn
Club and could even drop some ill rhymes
banks showed unchanged
cuz now he's grinding away at the same
broke-ass job
it's Tom Amanda stuffs Laura Brasa them
titties looking fine then she dropped
the big news the cat dropping by is Jim
Laura wigs out so hard that when the
boys arrived
Laura chokes and got a dip out to
another room damn Laura
Jimmy Tom chilling converse a bout the
warehouse apparently Tom about to get
the boot but he already got plans to
join the merchant seaman's Union matter
of fact he signed up using a chat if he
was opposed to pay the electric bill
with Amanda buses in jabbering again
about how all the brothers want her back
then and it's all sipping a challenge to
BAM the lights go out they spark some
candles and a man to tell Jim to pull up
a glass of wine for Lord Jim start
throwing game at Laura
Carla her old fashioned type of girl and
say he never noticed her janky leg back
in high school
Laura talking about school in her glass
collection when Jill said girl you so
fly you don't even know you just need
some confidence boo then Laura show him
her favorite thing a glass unicorn
Jim here's somebody dropping some fresh
beats nearby so he has Laura to dance
they bringing it on a dance floor when
crash that unicorn gets busted brother
thinking he gotta build her confidence
so he kiss her but then immediately
recognizes hitam [ __ ] up cuz turns out
he getting married next month
damn Laura gives him the broken unicorn
as a souvenir
she thinks when a man that comes in Jim
say yo gotta bounce I'm engaged thanks
for the dinner and a unicorn though
Amanda just a bouncer so it starts
getting crunk on Tom say he made them
look like fools bring a home an engaged
man
he ain't nothing but a selfish [ __ ]
whose head is always in the clouds
Tom chunks deuce is out of that trap to
get his adventure on but no matter how
far he go you're always thinking of his
post system this play is a choice
example of what my boys he will cause
plastic beer and in the PT gang
everything on stage I'm talking props
sounds music lighting repping the things
that's going on inside the characters
domes and in the Glass Menagerie all
that mess is showing how to win Phil
family's dreams ain't jiving with
reality so he remember this crew got
some fantasy world that they living in
Laurel spent her days chillin with her
Glass Menagerie creating the place where
Shane got a deal with all them real-life
[ __ ] her mama always dogging her not
being shy buggin out at school I could
go on play and Williams getting on his
plastic theater Jam described the
reality of Loris situation by comparing
her to that glass just peep the stage
direction be a fragile unearthly
prettiness has come out in Laura she is
like a piece of translucent glass
touched by light giving a momentary
radiance not actual that lasted but that
glass collection ain't the only thing
reppin Laura Laura called blue roses cuz
she is a blue rose she mad sensitive are
always feeling blue and got a unique
kind of beauty that you don't usually
find in the hood that'd be easy am and
are always living in the past when she
was a sexy southern belle who could get
any brother with just one twerk now she
a single mom who got burned by some
little [ __ ] and is now living a bleak
as life that disparity between life and
her mind and life on the real making her
act like a damn fool like when her
wrinkly ass was wearing a dress made for
some young who jeez
tom dream about writing and living an
adventurous lifestyle since grinding at
the warehouse is hella weak boy talk
smack to his mama and even boost cash
from the family just to add flavor to
his own game
even though he peaced out to live
my life surprise surprise sometimes your
dreams get it on by reality boys future
become just as bunk as his past I was
pursued by something all at once my
sister touches my shoulder I turn around
and look into her eyes Oh Laura Laura I
tried to leave you behind me but I am
more faithful than I intended to be Jem
was top dog in high school but now he a
low-level scrub busting his ass at a
warehouse but even he living in a world
of bullsh said he taking public speaking
courses that's gonna shoot him to the
top boy please the only way these cats
can escape the prison that they realized
is the light of themselves over and over
till it sticks
he will swing a repetition all our
business checks to make that point
Amanda always talking about some flower
called John quills to bring her back to
the good old days of pranking tennis and
rich horn dogs hollering so lovely that
country in May literally flooded with
John quills that was the summer I had
the craze for John quills John quills
became an absolute obsession mother said
honey there's no more room for John
quills and I still kept on bringing in
more John quills whenever wherever I saw
him I said stop stop I see John quills I
made the young men help me gather the
John quills it was a joke a man they
heard John quills finally there were no
more bosses to hold them every available
space was filled with John quills town
keep dropping the words movies and move
the shall we engine to escape this type
of flow is a special kind of repetition
carpel impotent when you repeat words
they got the same roots yes movies look
at them you know what happens people go
to the movies instead of moving I'm
tired of the movies and I am about the
move man is show do suck a fat one when
you recognize that your life and gonna
never be the fantasy in your head the
hard truth is that for the madness Tom's
and Laura's of the world sometimes there
ain't nothing better you can do then put
reality to the side and escape the cloud
9 yo thanks for keeping it 100 with me
next time hey and yo one more thing
before you go cuz we've got big news
this year we've launched an audio series
thug notes get lit in each episode I
dive into list of the trailers writers
characters plots themes and more all
from the world of literature so if you
like what your boy doc sweet does here
on thug notes check out thug notes get
lit it's available on iTunes and all
these spots you find podcasts and as
always we've got lots more videos on the
way so click here to go to our channel
page and if you haven't already make
sure to subscribe while you're there
catch y'all next time players peace
[Music]
you